why don't you put it on the grill it's
better than nothing you don't want it to
be too bright yo we're back Sam and Nico
with the questions and tips these five
hidden secrets are gonna piss off
contest judges around the world a lot of
people have asked us how to make the
best contest entry video a lot of you
guys do like 48 hour film competitions
there's a ton of competitions that
happen online so if the Doritos crash
the Super Bowl contest going if you're
good this is a perfect opportunity to
jump in and give you guys all the tips
on how to make the best 30 second video
possible which by nature falls into
being probably the best contest entry
video possible so let's launch into it
well let's launch pro tip 1 to write a
good short video it's all about the hook
can you give people a reason to watch
and a reason to get their friends to
watch if you look at for example potion
overdose the hook Wizards who drink so
much potions and they vomit ok great
but now you need a short story two
wizards standing in an alleyway battling
there at the end of the line they can't
harness enough power to defeat each
other so they turn to all their potions
they're just chugging them as fast as
they can they start to vomit and it's
the end of the world for them so you
take that hook you develop it into a
story
now when structuring these videos it's
really important to remember that third
part of this three-part structure and
that's really your punchline it's the
most memorable part of your video
because that's what people see last and
the way to really kind of structure that
or you know conceptualize that is you
take your hook you take your main idea
and your concept and you always want to
involve it like either one step further
or introduce something that you kind of
just toss in the beginning and kind of
come full circle with it at the end of
the day think of your short video like a
three panel comic strip in the newspaper
that's the best way I can describe it if
you're just making a video version of
that little strip you read you'll get
the punchy quick to the point setup
that'll play out in just the right
amount of time for your thirty seconds
now 30 seconds isn't a lot of time to
convey information so you have to rely
on that old saying a picture is worth a
thousand words what you want to do is
you want to tell your story visually you
can show your character you can show us
around them
you have the scene you have the context
of their expression on their face all
these
come together to tell the viewer what's
happening so utilize what's in your
scene and your actors to convey as much
information as possible that will be key
to making a really tight 30-second video
all right
so in considering the piece and how
you're designing it make sure that
you're always taking into consideration
how to simplify things how to just
distill this concept and make sure that
anything you're communicating and and
putting in this video all revolves
around that core concept going back to
the comic strip example you'll notice
that in most comics they're very
simplified there's no visual noise or
unneeded drawing in illustration most
are simply the two characters or even
one expressing the joke idea and
punchline and make sure that you're
considering that simplification in your
piece so that people can only focus on
that hook that you're trying to convey
so where do you get your inspiration for
a short story or a 30-second video the
answer is to look for something that is
common and an everyday experience for
people something that resonates with the
human experience for example in our
kittens on the beat video we took the
idea of having one of your socks go
missing from a pair which is something
that people will mention here and there
as a joke forever you have your hook and
you have your unique idea that can be
either an actual joke or just like some
visual thing you're doing like a cat in
a funny costume but the thing is is that
it's nothing without context and context
gives a piece purpose what is context
exactly well context is a guy who's got
magic powers versus a guy who has to use
his magic powers to clean the dishes and
that context is what actually drives the
majority of pieces and actually kind of
gives gives the video or short film a
shape it's not you got a killer concept
you guys start shooting it now what's
the trick to making something look
really nice
the answer is professional camera moves
smooth sweeping shots pushing in pulling
out or moving around that kind of convey
the emotion of the scene I know it's
really amateur shaky camera boo what's
really professional the lighting cameras
that are
disconnected from reality how's this
camera moving like this people can't
possibly move a camera smoothly through
the air how does the average filmmaker
go out and get smooth camera motion the
answer is with warp stabilizer and After
Effects and we got your toil on our
channel for those people want to figure
out how to do that also don't
underestimate the power of a tripod or
simply resting your camera on a still
object it does the exact same thing that
Nico's camera moves do and that is
removing your hands from the camera
disassociating this scene in this image
from the user error that you get when
doing handheld shaky camera yeah if
there's one lighting element you can add
to your scene to make your actors look
really sharp
it's an edge light an edge light
separates your actor from the background
and you can get crazy fill and keys and
all that kind of stuff but most
important is an edge light super easy
just get a light kind of off to the side
behind your actor and point it at them
and you'll get your edge light what does
the nuts like do Niko told it separates
the action from the background already
mentioned it oh nice another thing that
really separates amateur from
professional videos is audio making sure
that you have crisp clear audio for your
dialogue and any sound effects happening
is super super important also trying to
eliminate background noise
one way that's really easy to do this in
case you don't have a microphone is to
take your cell phone go to a voice
recording app like that and then slip it
into a shirt pocket or something nearby
that way this will act as your nice
clean super closed microphone that will
record all your dialogue all you got to
do is email the frickin file it's
yourself later and then put it in your
timeline done look what I just did
does your nice clean super close
microphone they'll record all your
dialogue so simple sound cues sound
design cues whooshes Rises bass drops
those work great to cue the audience
into how they should be feeling it and
where that emotional impact is coming
from a great way to get a rise or swell
is to take thunder or an explosion and
play it backwards
you get like a kind of noise working
some whooshes Rises swooshes swishes
bass drops all that kind of stuff it'll
make up for not having a sweet 30-second
song in your music track for those of
you wanting to put the effects in your
piece consider this rather than packing
the entire thing with shot after shot of
the effects make sure you save it for
that one important moment where it
really needs it if you're using up all
these VFX spectacle cards and tossing
them all around your piece it's gonna
water it down save your time and effort
into that one moment that really needs
it dummy you know what when you're
editing your piece make sure you edit
down all the fat you don't want to waste
my time right you don't want to waste
everyone else's time right
just do it I got this you know what you
don't have time for in your video I'll
tell you why it's all the fat I got to
edit down all the little omens that
don't make any sense it's just take a
pace in 30 seconds you don't have time
to waste time on anything you know whose
time you don't want to waste mine you
know who else's the entire world done
chances are if you're making a video for
a contest of 30 seconds long it's
probably gonna be a funny video they're
gonna want some quality acting in that
video but how do you get some quality
acting don't have your actor overact or
hand things up or be too self-aware the
character should always be taking things
100% seriously in the piece they need to
be real in the world needs to be real
it's a situation being ridiculous and
the
you were seeing how ridiculous it is
that makes it funny if your character
knows it's ridiculous it stops being
funny so your character take it
seriously let everything else be
ridiculous another way to say this is
you want your audience to laugh at the
joke not your characters now you're
armed with a knowledge that it's gonna
take to take over the contest world you
guys should go and enter the doritos
contest and if you do you should tweeted
us a link to your piece because we'd
love to see how you guys have taken this
information and apply it to the pieces
that you do so yeah feel free to share
with us our twitter is at corridor
digital and yeah there's like a million
dollars for the grand prize and one
person gets to go on the set of Marvel's
The Avengers 2 age of Ultron and work on
that which is pretty neat yeah a million
bucks an actual on set professional film
production experience is a lot more than
we have so if the person who wins
happens to be a person who watches this
video you should totally tweet us a
picture of yourself like on set like
waving tweet a picture of your millions
ask for it like a big like suitcases
yeah wait a second if we know all the
secrets for the contest
why don't we just Center
you